game of life is a very simple example of
reaching for order when there's an
excess of energy
or reaching for order and somehow
creating complexity it within like this
this explosion of just
turmoil
somehow trying to construct structures
and so doing
uh creates very elaborate
organism-looking type things
what intuition do you draw from this
simple a mechanism well i i like to turn
that around on its head and um
and look at it as what if every single
one of the patterns created
life or created you know not life but
created interesting patterns because you
know some of them don't and sometimes
you make cool gliders and other times
you know you start with certain things
and you make gliders and other things
that then construct like you know and
gates and not gates right and you build
computers on them
all of these rules that create these
patterns that we can see
those are just the patterns we can see
what if our subjectivity is actually
limiting our ability to perceive
the order in all of it
you know what if some of the things that
we think are random or actually not that
random we're simply not integrating at a
final level across a broad enough time
horizon
um and this is again i said we go down
the rabbit holes and the penrose stuff
or like wolf runs explorations on these
things um
there is something deep and beautiful in
the mathematics of all this that is
hopefully one day i'll have enough money
to work and retire and just ponder those
those questions but there's something
there but you're saying there's a
ceiling to when you have enough money
and you retire and you ponder it there's
a ceiling to how much you can truly
ponder because there's cognitive
limitations
in what you're able to
perceive as a pattern
yeah so and maybe mathematics extends
your
perception capabilities but it's still
it's still finite it's just like
yeah the mathematics we use is the
mathematics that can fit in our head
yeah
you know did god really create the
integers or did god create all of it and
we just happen at this point in time to
be able to perceive integers
well she just did the the positive in
there
and then we
um
she just graded the natural numbers and
then we screwed all up with zero and
then i guess okay
but we did we created mathematical uh
operations so we can have iterated steps
to approach bigger problems
right i mean the entire the entire point
of the arabic numeral system and it's a
rubric for mapping a certain set of
operations or folding them into a simple
little expression
but that's just the operations that we
can fit in our heads
there are many other operations besides
right
the thing that worries me the most about
aliens and humans
is that their aliens are all around us
and we're too dumb
yeah see them oh certainly yeah or life
let's say just life life of all kinds of
forms or organisms you know what just
even the intelligence of organisms
is uh imperceptible to us because we're
too dumb and self-centered that works
well we're looking for a particular kind
of thing yeah
when i was at cornell i had a lovely
professor of asian religions jamerry law
and she would tell this um story about a
musical a musician a western musician
who went to japan and he taught you know
classical music and
could play you know all sorts of
instruments he went to japan um and he
would ask people you know he would
basically be looking for things in the
style of
western
you know chromatic scale and these kinds
of things and then finding none of it he
would say well there's really no music
in japan but they're using a different
scale they're playing different kinds of
instruments right the same thing she was
using as sort of a metaphor for religion
as well and the west we center a lot of
religion certainly the the religions of
abraham we center them around belief and
in the east it's more about practice
right spirituality and practice rather
than belief so anyway the point is here
to your point um life we i think so many
people are so fixated on certain aspects
of self-replication
or you know homeostasis or whatever but
if we kind of broaden and generalize
this thing of things reaching for order
under which conditions can they then
create an environment that sustains that
order
that um allows them you know the
the invention of death is an interesting
thing there are some organisms on earth
that are thousands of years old
and it's not like they're incredibly
complex they're actually simpler than
the cells that comprise us
but they never die so at some point
death was invented you know somewhere
along the eukaryotic scale i mean even
the protists right there's death
and why is that along with the sexual
reproduction
right there is something about
the renewal process something about the
ability to respond to a changing
environment
where
it just becomes you know just killing
off the old generation and letting new
generations
try seems to be the best way to fit into
the niche you know human historians
seems to write about wheels and fires
the greatest inventions but it seems
like death and sex are pretty good and
they're kind of essential inventions at
the very beginning at the very beginning
yeah well we didn't invent them right
well broad we
you didn't invest life i see us as one
uh you particular homo sapien did not
invent them but uh we together it's a
team project just like you're saying i
think the greatest homo sapien
invention is collaboration
you